well sally we are just about an hour
away from valentine's day and love is in
the air of course we live in the wedding
capital of the world so that means a lot
of people will head out to get hitched
madison kimbrough joins us live from
lucky little wedding chapel downtown
with more madison
from pop-up wedding chapels to
stationary ones just like the one that
you see behind me the wedding capital of
the world is seeing an influx of couples
this february and it's not just because
of valentine's day
it's been great it's been busy we have
people even today calling in for
tomorrow then all of a sudden we get
more and more online bookings and phone
calls tis the season for love as couples
flock here to the wedding capital of the
world and to keep up lucky little
wedding chapel in downtown las vegas has
increased their space to accommodate the
masses so we have two permanent
chapels here at our facility and then we
created with the help of the city we
kind of created two pop-ups the clark
county clerk's office tells me they are
expecting to issue their 5 millionth
marriage license this month since the
county was founded in 1909 it's also the
fourth year the office has opened a
temporary marriage license bureau at
reed international for arriving
passengers operating until february 22nd
they can get off the plane grab their
bags and then pick up their marriage
license before they even get your taxi
so that's been very popular
both for the couples and for the airport
and for our
bureau as for the upcoming palindrome
date of february 22nd 2022 goya says
many chapels are already booked up so
couples can head to wedding chamber dot
vegas for a full list of chapels still
available
when speaking to the owner here at lucky
little wedding chapel it seems they have
more bookings for the upcoming
palindrome date then for valentine's day
tomorrow they're saying that's going to
be about 120 ceremonies on the 22nd and
that doesn't even include walk-ins
reporting live from downtown madison
kimbrough live local now
all right madison well are you still